>> Tucker: A POLITICIAN'S JOB
IS TO APPEAL TO VOTERS.
IT LEFT LEANING VOTERS DON'T
LIKE THE NRA.
PAT DAVIS IS A DEMOCRAT RUNNING
FOR CONGRESS IN NEW MEXICO.
PUT TWO AND TWO TOGETHER AND
DAVIS HAS PRODUCED A NEW AD
WHERE HE EXPRESSES HIS VIEW OF
THE NRA UNAMBIGUOUSLY, BUT YOU
DECIDE.
>> [BLEEP] THE NRA.
THEIR PROGRAM POLICIES HAVE
RESULTED IN DEAD CHILDREN, DEAD
MOTHERS AND DEAD FATHERS.
I'M PAT DAVIS AND I APPROVED
THIS MESSAGE BECAUSE IF CONGRESS
WON'T CHANGE OUR GUN LAWS, WE
ARE CHANGING CONGRESS.
>> Tucker: PAT DAVIS JOINS US
TONIGHT FROM NEW MEXICO.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> HI, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE AD?
KIND OF MORONIC, NO?
>> THAT'S IT, JUST 15 SECONDS,
BUT IT GOT A WHOLE LOT OF
ATTENTION AND STARTED A NEW
CONVERSATION ABOUT GUNS AND I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
>> Tucker: DOESN'T IT DEGRADE
YOU?
YOU USE THE F WORD IN THE AD.
YOU HAVE A POSITION STATED, BUT
>> BEING THE LIGHT HASN'T MADE
OUR SCHOOLS IN HIS FAVOR.
IT HASN'T PROTECTED POLICE
OFFICERS LIKE I USED TO BE.
IF A CUSS WORD ON TV OFFENDS YOU
MORE THAN DEAD CHILDREN IN
PARKLAND OR NEWTOWN THEN YOUR
PRIORITIES ARE WRONG.
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT EITHER/OR.
I DON'T CARE IF YOU ARE A COP OR
NOT.
IT'S NOT AN EITHER OR.
IT'S NOT THAT I'M SO OFFENDED.
DO YOU THINK RUDENESS WILL?
IS RUDENESS GOING TO SAVE LIVES
DO YOU THINK?
>> AS WE WERE LOOKING TO MAKE
THIS AD, WHAT WE SAID -- WE KEPT
COMING UP WITH THE SAME IDEA AND
EVERY ADD, THIS ISSUE LOOKED
LIKE SOMEBODY ELSE'S AND THOSE
HAD NOT WORKED.
CLEARLY THIS GOT THE NRA'S
ATTENTION AND IT HAS STARTED THE
NEW CONVERSATION BOTH AMONGST
CANDIDATES RUNNING FOR OFFICE
ABOUT WHO -- HOW WE ORGANIZE AND
TAKE BACK CONGRESS AND PUT THE
LEADERS THERE AND TAKE BACK ON
CONTROL.
AND ALSO HOW WE STAND UP TO THE
NRA.
WE KNOW WHAT WORKS.
50% OF NRA MEMBERS SUPPORT --
>> Tucker: A CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW EMBARRASSING YOU ARE.
HOW MANY NRA MEMBERS HAVE
COMMITTED MASS SHOOTINGS?
>> TUCKER, HERE'S THE THING.
A MAJORITY OF AMERICA'S -- 89%
OF POLICE OFFICERS, A MAJORITY
OF NRA KNOW THERE ARE
COMMON SENSE THINGS WE CAN DO.
>> Tucker: YOU JUST RELEASED
AN AD THAT SAID F THE NRA WHICH
I'M SURE BACK AT YOUR FRATERNITY
HOUSE THEY LOVE.
BUT LET ME ASK YOU ONE ADULT
QUESTION, HOW MANY NRA MEMBERS
HAVE COMMITTED MASS SHOOTINGS?
>> TUCKER, THIS IS ABOUT THE
ORGANIZATION ITSELF.
MY FAMILY GREW UP --
>> Tucker: I'M ASKING YOU
ABOUT THE ORGANIZATION ITSELF.
>> IT'S NOT THE NRA THAT MY DAD
ORGANIZATION.
>> Tucker: HOW MANY OF THEIR
MEMBERS -- THEY HAVE MILLIONS OF
MEMBERS.
HOW MANY OF THEM --
>> I'VE BEEN HEARING FROM THEM
ALL WEEK.
I'VE BEEN HEARING FROM THEM ALL
WEEK.
THE NRA MADE US THEIR TARGET.
WE STARTED A NEW CONVERSATION
AND WHAT I'VE ALSO HEARD FROM
OUR PARENTS IN HYDE PARK WHEN,
IN VIRGINIA AND NEWTOWN WHO
DONATED TO KEEP THE OUT ON THE
AIR BECAUSE THEY WANT PEOPLE IN
CONGRESS TO FINALLY STEP UP.
IF THE NRA WANTS TO COME TO THE
TABLE AND HELP US PASS
COMMON SENSE REGULATIONS THAT
THEIR MEMBER SUPPORT, LET'S DO
IT.
WE ARE NOT WAITING ON THEM TO
COME TO THE TABLE.
>> Tucker: TRYING TO HAVE AN
ADULT CONVERSATION.
HERE IS YOUR NEW SPOT.
I WANT TO TALK THE POLICY AND
SEE WHAT YOU KNOW ABOUT IT.
HERE'S YOUR LATEST 152ND AD.
>> BY THE TIME THIS AD IS DONE
IN AR-15 COULD HAVE FIRED 150
BULLETS.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO BAN
ASSAULT WEAPONS.
I'M PAT DAVIS, RUNNING FOR
CONGRESS AND I APPROVED THIS
MESSAGE BECAUSE LIVES ARE MORE
IMPORTANT THAN GUN COMPANY
PROFITS.
>> Tucker: SO YOU JUST SAID
THAT IN 15 SECONDS AND AR-15 CAN
FIRE 150 ROUNDS.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU GET IT RIGHT HERE IN
NEW MEXICO.
RIGHT HERE IN NEW MEXICO YOU CAN
GO TO A PARKING LOT OR GO ON THE
INTERNET, BUY AN ASSAULT WEAPON,
AND AR-15 AND BY A LEGALLY
AVAILABLE ADD-ON LIKE A BOMB
STOCK THAT ALLOWS YOU TO
REPLICATE EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED
IN LAS VEGAS.
THE LAS VEGAS SHOOTER 600 ROUNDS
A MINUTE.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE SAYING AND
AR-15 CAN SHOOT 150 ROUNDS IN 15
SECONDS.
LET ME ASK, LET'S BE SPECIFIC.
IF YOU ARE AT.
WHAT WITH THAT MAGAZINE LOOK
LIKE YOU MIKE THE 150 ROUND
MAGAZINE.
>> EXACTLY LIKE THE MAGAZINES
THAT LAS VEGAS POLICE OFFICERS
PULLED OUT OF THAT HOTEL ROOM.
>> Tucker: THERE WERE 150
ROUND --
>> 50 AND 100 ROUND MAGAZINE.
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT.
THESE ARE RHETORICAL QUESTIONS.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
I KNOW THAT YOU ARE A POLICE
OFFICER.
NO AR-15 CAN FIRE 150 ROUNDS IN
15 SECONDS.
THAT'S UNTRUE AND IF YOU BELIEVE
IT IS TRUE THEN YOU ARE NOT
QUALIFIED TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT GUNS.
PEOPLE ARE LAUGHING AT YOU
BECAUSE YOU ARE IGNORANT.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
>> WE TAKE EXACTLY THE WORD OF
THE POLICE OFFICERS IN LAS VEGAS
WHO I TRUST WHO RAN INTO THAT
ROOM TO SAVE PEOPLE DOWN BELOW
AND FOUND A WEAPON MODIFIED WITH
FARM STOCKS.
>> Tucker: SO THEY SAY AND
AR-15 -- WHAT DO YOU THINK WOULD
HAPPEN TO THE BARREL IN 15
SECONDS IF YOU PUT 150 ROUNDS --
IT WOULD MELT.
>> I KNOW THEY GET HOT.
>> Tucker: BEING MR. TOUGH, I
WAS A COP GUY, MAYBE YOU SHOULD
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT,
BUT YOU DON'T.
YOU ARE PUTTING ON TELEVISION
SOMETHING THAT IS DEMONSTRABLY
WRONG AND PHYSICALLY POSSIBLE
AND ALL OF YOUR VOTERS ARE LIKE
THIS GUY KNOWS WHAT HE'S TALKING
ABOUT, HE WAS A COP, BUT YOU
DON'T KNOW SO MAYBE YOU SHOULD
APOLOGIZE FOR IT.
>> I'M NOT APOLOGIZING FOR
ANYTHING.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOU SHOULD
APOLOGIZE FOR SAYING SOMETHING
THAT IS FACTUALLY UNTRUE.
>> WE NEED NEW FOCUS.
THIS WILL BE A PRIORITY.
>> Tucker: BUT YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, SO
MAYBE YOU SHOULDN'T BE IN A
POSITION TO MAKE DECISIONS
BECAUSE YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
ISSUE BECAUSE YOU JUST TOLD ME
WITH A STRAIGHT FACE THAT IN
AR-15 CAN FIRE 150 ROUNDS IN 15
SECONDS.
IT CAN'T.
MAYBE YOU SHOULD ADMIT THAT AND
MOVE ON TO SOMETHING YOU
UNDERSTAND, WOULD YOU DO THAT?
>> THIS IS EXACTLY THE TYPE OF
ARGUMENTS THAT DON'T GET US
WHERE WE NEED TO BE.
WE NEED NEW -- WE ARE MOVING --
>> Tucker: I THOUGHT
POLITENESS DIDN'T WORK, TOUGH
GUY?
>> POLITENESS IS NOT WORKING SO
FAR.
YOU WANT SOMEBODY IN CONGRESS TO
STEP UP.
>> Tucker: WHY DON'T YOU GET
SOME FACTS?
DO LIKE THIS NEW MODE OF
COMMUNICATION WE HAVE?